Hola Andrés Buenas noches sí
efectivamente una primera lectura podría
decir que el presidente borich Hace un
giro hacia el centro cosa que ha venido
haciendo desde la instalación del
gabinete desde la modificación de su
campaña incluso y desde la incorporación
de algunas ministras ya en septiembre
ministras que son o hacen parte de la
que fue la concertación y evidentemente
se acerca al centro político al ppd al
partido socialista ahora también
respecto de este cambio en particular Yo
creo que es un giro hacia el centro pero
no muy bien logrado han habido errores
significativos en el cambio de gabinete
hoy errores por ejemplo respecto de la
prolijidad respecto de las lo que
circulaba hubo una ministra de
relaciones exteriores casi nombrada que
debe bajarse minutos antes de ser de
estar dentro del del decreto del
nombramiento por algunos problemas
referentes a dicho de esta misma
ministra es decir hubo desprolijidad en
este cambio y además yo creo que no
despeja algo a pesar de moverse al
centro no despeja algunos hoy día por
ejemplo este gobierno que es el primer
gobierno en Chile que se ha declarado
feminista se abre una crítica en torno a
por ejemplo haber reemplazado tres
ministras mujeres y no haberlas
sustituido con tres ministra mujeres
sino con tres ministros hombres al mismo
tiempo un ministro como el ministro
Ávila de Educación que había ya el día
de ayer He sido criticado por por grupos
feministas por un altercado que había
tenido con una diputada permanece dentro
del gabinete es decir quedan aún
presentes varios elementos que a pesar
de que el presidente haga un giro hacia
el centro van a seguir allí como una
piedra en el zapato esto sin mencionar
algunos elementos de satisfacción de los
mismos partidos políticos yo creo que
aquí el presidente también se abrió
algunos flancos respecto a cuánto los
partidos algunos de los partidos se van
a sentir representados en este cambio de
carabineros
dijo que estos cambios no obedecen a
presiones políticas mientras que por
otro lado se habla de una crisis
ministerial realmente se ve así
yo creo que estos cambios y y aquí hay
que ser ir más allá de lo políticamente
correcto en cualquier parte del mundo
los cambios de gabinete responden en una
muy buena parte a presiones políticas a
equilibrios políticos que los gobiernos
deben tener en virtud de las fuerzas que
están detrás apoyándolos también
evidentemente son cambios que se
orientan a mejorar la gestión y en
algunos casos Como por ejemplo puede ser
la ministra de deporte sí sin lugar a
dudas habían elementos de mala gestión
que hacen parte de la explicación de Por
qué se cambia el gabinete en estricto
rigor ahora también hay otros elementos
y es bueno que se tengan presente y se
tengan sobre la mesa que son elementos
partidistas y en ese sentido
evidentemente yo creo que ahí el
presidente dice lo que le corresponde
decir en su calidad de presidente de la
república pero evidentemente detrás hay
elementos partidistas que presionaron y
además el entorno mediático de hecho
creo que algunas improvisaciones que hoy
día pudimos ver en el cambio de gabinete
se debe a que justamente responder a las
presiones de la prensa las presiones de
los partidos políticos no daba margen a
interpretar Qué elementos del cambio de
gabinete eran propios del gobierno y no
habían sido presionados Entonces nos
encontramos con algunas sorpresas que
habría que entrar en en analizarla y
entender qué explicación tienen como por
ejemplo ministerios que no habían
aparecido en la prensa u otros que
estaban siendo cuestionados Y no y
terminaron no saliendo del gabinete
existiendo válidos motivos para para su
cuestionamiento Entonces evidentemente
yo creo que aquí es una Está compuesto
por distintos factores Este cambio y el
político partidista es uno de ellos y es
uno central ahora Boris cumple mañana un
año desde que asumió el cargo qué logros
alcanzado y Qué desafíos tiene por
delante
Mira yo creo que cumple un año y hace
dos días se cayó la reforma madre de
todo el programa de gobierno del
presidente borich es decir no obstante
haya recuperado la percepción positiva
por parte de la ciudadanía en el último
tiempo sobre todo a partir de la gestión
de algunos de sus ministros y ministras
en los incendios que afectaron el sur de
país de febrero y ha subido en las
encuestas Lamentablemente hace dos días
fue rechazada la reforma tributaria y la
reforma tributaria era una condicionante
particular respecto de la implementación
de todo el programa de gobierno por
tanto este gabinete ASUME con la difícil
tarea de Buscar implementar reformas o
simplemente proyectos de ley ya ni
siquiera reformas profundas sin tener
las espaldas cubiertas con una reforma
tributaria que permita financiarlas
entonces este yo creo que va a ser un
gabinete que más bien va a tener que
sortear obstáculos tratar de Navegar lo
más tranquilo posible pero de ahí a
hablar Que sea un gabinete que pueda
imprimir una velocidad mayor para
conseguir las metas y objetivos que está
que este gobierno se ha planteado desde
el inicio yo sinceramente lo veo
bastante difícil